hoy en directo vamos a hablar de los 365
días del estado de excepción en El
Salvador una medida que en principio fue
decretada como una emergencia ante los
altísimos indios índices de inseguridad
pero que cumple un año en vigor y deja
más de 66.000 detenidos sí los reportes
oficiales sí muestran una baja en la
inseguridad pero a un elevado costo en
materia de violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos según denuncian algunas
organizaciones estas organizaciones
hablan de miles de denuncias conectamos
con Andrés Suárez Jaramillo corresponsal
de France 24 Andrés qué balance entrega
el gobierno de nayib bukele a un año de
haberse implementado este régimen de
excepción
Valentina Buenas noches haciendo gala de
sus resultados el presidente nayib
bukele despuntó la madrugada De este
lunes con un trino en el que hacía
alusión que hace exactamente un año en
El Salvador se cerraba el día con 62
homicidios es el día más mortífero
registrado en este país centroamericano
desde que terminó la guerra civil en
1992 y después bukele dijo que un año
después se cierra el día con cero
homicidios y probablemente el mes de
marzo de 2023 sea el más seguro de su
historia aunque no tan extenso como
otros regímenes de excepción que se han
vivido en países como Siria Egipto los
países europeos durante la Segunda
Guerra Mundial el de El Salvador se fue
prorrogando mes a mes en contra de la
Constitución y se convirtió en Norma una
norma que han aprovechado los policías y
la fuerza Pública para realizar
operativos como cercos militares a
soyapango a otras colonias donde siempre
mandaron y operaban las pandillas
insignias del la Mara Salvatrucha 13 y
barrio 18 y de esta forma el gobierno
entrega que se han realizado más de
66.200 capturas en las colonias donde
antiguamente pues no se podía salir de
noche era un imposible ahora se respira
Paz según encuestas que han hecho
periodistas y esto le ha dado una gran
popularidad al presidente nayib bukele
Pero la pregunta era dónde meter hasta
66,000 personas pues se construyó una
mega cárcel en tiempo récord y allí ya
hay 4000 detenidos que se dice que
muchos de ellos pasarán toda su vida y
cuáles son las principales críticas en
este primer año de régimen de excepción
los reparos salieron a flote conforme se
fueron apilando las denuncias primero en
decenas luego en miles en materia de
cifras se contabilizan más de 100
muertos bajo custodia Estatal Durante
este año de régimen de excepción y se
han consignados más de 7.900 denuncias
de violaciones a los Derechos Humanos la
mayoría de estas relacionadas con
detenciones arbitrarias de jóvenes que
simplemente por tener tatuajes pues
fueron aprendidos de una manera injusta
no tenían ninguna relación con las
pandillas muchos de ellos pasaron
semanas algunos meses y denunciaron que
En aquellos centros penitenciarios
sufrieron torturas otra de las fuertes
críticas la realizó el alto comisionado
de las Naciones Unidas para los derechos
humanos en abril del año pasado al
señalar que el congreso salvadoreño
modificó la legislación para enjuiciar a
los adolescentes de 13 A 17 años como si
fueran adultos y poderlos meter a las
cárceles y una última
es la de que bukele por su popularidad
pues es manifestó lanzarse a una
reelección esto en contra de la
constitución del Salvador